let's now speak to Marta Herrera who is
live for us in Madrid Marta we've seen
yet another sharp rise in the death toll
what are authoritative out the today the
trajectory of all of this well as you
said is a very grim day for Spain with
the figures that has been given by the
Health Ministry we know that nearly
8,000 people have been infected and 738
people died from from coronavirus in the
last 24 hours
Health Minister sources say that this
Spain is reaching its peak the peak of
the curve in this coronavirus situation
but people are not very don't rely very
much in this because we've got no test
kids testing kits for coronavirus and
many people are staying at home with all
the symptoms Marta we've also been
seeing the military out and about
disinfecting places over the last few
days and they're also helping to
maintain that lockdown now also a
request for NATO partners to help
what are authoritative on though well
Spanish government has asked NATO
through the Defense Ministry to provide
coronavirus testing kits ventilators and
protecting gear as this is becoming one
if not the main problem of a space fight
facing that Spain is facing to find the
hope endemic Marta Herrera there live
for us in Madrid thank you very much for
that update Martha